Speaker 1: All right, a few notable posts
on The David Pakman Show subreddit.
Now here I'm not selling you anything.
Many times I am selling you things here.
I'm not.
You can go to David Pakman dot com slash Reddit,
where nearly 34000 of our viewers and listeners
have subscribed for free.
And you can post about the show.
You can talk to other viewers and listeners
about what's in the news.
There's some things you're not allowed to
do because it's a little bit over the line,
but there's a lot of things you can do it
David Pakman dot com slash Reddit, one user
posted on the scene.
Correspondance has been my favorite addition
to the David Pakman show.
Seriously, David, it's incredibly entertaining,
but also wildly useful to get real feedback
from these events.
I don't know if Josh or Luke wind up being
recurring correspondents, but I loved watching
them.
Maybe one of the larger events you or Pat
could get out in the field to add there would
be some security concerns.
Keep this kind of segment going.
Yeah, the point is taken.
The feedback to having two people on the ground
in Conroe, Texas, for the rally was fantastic.
And the incredible thing is because you all
are everywhere, all over the country.
It is very clear that if there is another
Trump rally in Tulsa, Oklahoma, maybe or wherever,
or if there is a, I don't know, an anti-vaccine
protest in wherever.
I think that we now have the audience size
where I can say, Hey, anybody in Berkeley,
California or wherever will pay you to go
and interview people at these events.
We don't have to fly people around.
We don't need, you know, all these different
things, and we can basically just take the
money because we want to compensate these
people for their time that that's the appropriate
thing to do, as we did with the Texas rally.
And we can say, well, because you're already
there, the money goes for your time rather
than having to to put money into expenses.
I think it's absolutely fantastic.
We're going to keep trying to do it.
And the one thing is we need to know about
the events early enough.
It's hard to say, Hey, can you go tomorrow?
So in terms of Trump rallies, right now, we're
not seeing anything else on Trump's calendar.
And we will we will see.
But one of the most valuable things is when
right wing media start some new story, whether
it's about 4G or Biden or whatever.
By having these correspondents on the ground,
we can immediately see whether it's gotten
to the Trumpists and whether they're aware
of it and how they're interpreting the new
talking points.
So it's a it's a fantastic thing and we are
going to keep doing it.
OK, another post on the subreddit David should
get in contact with Carhart about being their
spokesman, and there's A. Absolutely.
I described so Carhart is a brand that has
announced their employees are required to
be vaccinated, and it's sort of a right wing
associated brand.
Now, I very I don't know that I want to say
ignorantly, but I was having trouble describing
what Carhart is, and I said Carhart is a popular
clothing brand for people who are out doing
work, chainsaws and whatever.
I meant that it is a brand of clothing that
I believe also has.
It's not only worn, but it has like protective
elements where I think the material is such
that it has some protection if you regularly
work with sharp objects.
I don't know anyway.
So someone made a made a funny image of Carhart
for people out doing work, chainsaws and whatever.
But in all seriousness, Carhart is not unique.
There are tons of companies that require their
employees to be vaccinated, and I think the
reason that the Carhart vaccine requirement
triggered so many people is that there is
heavy association between Carhart and sort
of working out for right wing male ideology.
But Carhart doing it, Carhart has said, you've
got to be vaccinated and a lot of right wingers
now burning their Carhart clothing.
Although what's funny is I think there are
Carhart items that are flame retardant because
of what they're designed for.
So it was actually a prop.
It was difficult to actually burn it, which
just makes it all the more funny.
Join the discussion at David Pakman dot com
slash Reddit.